okay okay okay okay okay okay
coffee on a Tuesday and vlog 38 laziness
being unwilling to use work or energy a
lazy person sometimes called slacker
couch potato nerdwriter bludger wait no
that's wrong a bludger is the furthest
thing from laziness a bludger is deadly
serious what I consider laziness to be
the Lex Luthor of my life which begs the
question was kryptonite really the
weakness of Superman or was it Lex
Luthor or was it love ludwig von mises
the austrian economist wrote the
expenditure of labour is deemed painful
not to work is considered a state of
affairs more satisfactory than working
leisure is other things being equal
prefer to travail people work only when
they value the return of labour higher
than the decrease in satisfaction
brought about by the curtailment of
leisure is that true I mean I remember
those days in college when I had a long
paper or test to finish and I thought to
myself if I just finish this I'll have
three or four days where I won't have to
do anything and it will be glorious I
was living for the gaps as it were those
times when I could just be lazy and even
now having worked at a real job for some
time I'm beginning to learn the meaning
of that classic loverboy song don't get
me wrong I have a great job but it's
still work and there are times when I
find myself daydreaming about my couch
my boxers Jersey Shore I've always felt
like this laziness wasn't me like it was
some disease I had contracted like my
bad work ethic was the result of being
spoiled as a kid or the coddling of
contemporary society I felt this way
because I couldn't change it I couldn't
excise it from myself all I had was my
fear of failure to fight it and when you
graduate from school when the
educational system spits you out it
dawns on you that if you don't make
money you're going to become homeless of
course you might be lucky enough to have
parents to help you out part of the way
but unless you're inheriting a large
fortune you're gonna have to figure it
out for yourself at that point you can
still use the fear of failure to guide
you or you can use the disappointment of
others or you can find something that
you really love that doesn't seem like
work at all never underestimate the
power of not wanting to disappoint your
mother that hard work is considered by
almost everyone of virtue but laziness
may in fact be our nature a lot of
animals are just lazy they only get what
they need and they just lounge around
for the rest of the time but theories
abound which give leisure and laziness
more credit for example in Ecclesiastes
14 it says wisdom is good together with
an inheritance or Schopenhauer the man
to whom nature and fate have granted the
blessing of wisdom will be most anxious
and careful to keep open the fountains
of happiness which he has in himself and
for this independence and leisure are
necessary the point is that leisure
those hours when we don't have to work
for our bread may be the best for
inspiration in fact the modern economy
echoes that sentiment somewhat the
virtuous phrase work hard has almost
totally been replaced with work smart or
work uniquely many like those in the web
development community use leisure to
their business Advanta be sure the terms
leisure and laziness have nuances of
their own suffice it to say that
complete laziness won't sustain and
total leisure doesn't exist in the realm
of practical life it comes down to a
dualistic mantra be happy make money
of wood okay Daily Grace we both know
you're getting my tweets to collaborate
so what I'm gonna do now is enlist all
the viewers watching this video to tweet
Daily Grace to collaborate with the nerd
writer why well because I'm handsome
because I'm charming because I'm well at
the moment I'm gassy but that you know
don't consider that powerhouse in the
kitchen mediocre at basketball the most
sonorous high-fives
you've ever received I have a heart of
gold and I desperately need surgery I've
been known to give massages
no no that's wrong i i like massages can
you give me a massage